(angelic music)
- Hi! I'm Liz, and I'm from the Midwest,
where we eat cheese curds.
When I moved out to Los Angeles,
I realized that most people
have never had these squeaky delights.
So I took to the streets of Hollywood,
to see if these people
were worth their cheddar.
- Hey what's up, I'm Justin.
- I'm Shaun
- [both] And we're from South Africa
- I'm Brian, from
Treasure Island, Florida.
- [man] South Dakota
- [man #2] South Africa
- [man] Long Island
- [woman] from L.A.
- [woman] Utah!
- [woman #2] Virginia
- [woman] Napa, California
- [man] I'm from Hollywood
- [man] Alaska
- [woman] Texas
- Chicago, Illinois, and I
have never had a cheese curd
- Let's fondue this.
- [voiceover] What does
it look like to you?
- [both] Earwax. (laughs)
- Is this really cheese? I don't know
- Isn't that like moldy cheese?
- A soggy cheese puff?
- Ew, there's... Ew.
- Oh my god. (man laughs)
I don't know what that is.
- That's gnarly. Wow.
- But it's delicious.
It's like a cheese fry.
- [girl] Not a huge fan.
- [man] It's really rubbery
- A cross between Velveeta and Easy Mac.
Made in a little girl's oven bake.
(sounds of disgust)
[man] I love it!
- It's rad that it
squeaks when you chew it.
- [woman] I can't do anymore
- [man] Not bad.
- It's like an orgasm in your mouth.
- I'd have them constantly
- [woman] I thought it wasn't
gonna taste good, honestly.
- [man] Yeah, it' s actually much better
than I thought it was going to be
- It's way better than normal cheese.
- Way better than normal cheese?!
- I would have them again
and again and again and again
and over and over and over.
- I didn't like the texture
- Can I try one more?
- [man in black shirt] It's
too rubbery, too chewy.
- [man in white shirt]
Never again, never again.
- It would be great to
get this in South Africa.
- I'd like to make a cheese curd pizza.
Where can I get this?
- [voiceover] Would you
guys eat this again?
- [man] I would definitely eat them again
- [man in purple shirt]
Number one, I love it.
- Yeah, right here
- [man in black shirt] Right here.
- Definitely, I'd give it a ten; top ten.
- Can I have some more?
- Alright guys, here's the cheese curd
taste test breakdown:
we got alot of these,
some of these, some of
these, and some of these.
People were pretty much
all over the board.
But either way, I think
everyone had a gouda time.
Sorry, that was cheesy. Okay.
(upbeat trumpet music)